it began with a claim of money
laundering at this petrol station it's
now a corruption scandal worth billions
the rich and the powerful in the dock
ordinary Brazilians furious and the
world's seventh biggest economy
paralyzed today it'll probably falls
President Dilma Rousseff from office not
for corruption but for lying to voters
about the country's debt it's a complex
and chaotic story of massive deceit
tension and anger in the Senate this
week accusers themselves among the
accused and her opponents say the
president's responsibility makeup resist
but ziggler subj aladdin if she's not
directly involved two senators they say
Perella told us how can she say she knew
nothing we're living in a grotesque
scenario where corruption scandals
spreading every minute yella yella chef
Louisville sample at some bowel repair
her supporters they were angry at her
looming impeachment blocking roads
across the country and in the places
where her workers party brought homes
and jobs they were paying her now with
their faith Francisco DRC's credits her
for rebuilding his and his sons lives
here you asked it that pasta helmet
since your I'm against impeachment he
says this is all about the discontent
with the government the poles though
shows sixty percent of Brazilians
support that impeachment alongside the
extraordinary futuristic architecture of
Brasilia there are now barriers to keep
supporters and protesters apart the
once-booming brazilian economy was
already faltering before this scandal
but now the country is stagnating
there's a growing recession the currency
is falling and there's massive
uncertainty because no one knows when or
how this crisis will end the president's
supporters so it is effectively a coup I
can easily buy some food I see as crisis
will deepen senators wow kappa / ebay
told us it is possible we'll see large
social unrest by the end of the year the
political world as distance itself from
brazilian society and reality Dilma will
stay on in the presidential palace while
her trial takes place but
out of power and mocked on her way the
posters read goodbye darling Greg Milam
Sky News Brasilia